zauberwürfel backstreet boys pokémon go
irgendwann ist jeder hype mal zu ende
ich bin hier auf der demokratie messe im
reichstag mal gucken wie lange es diesen
ladenhüter überhaupt noch lebt
[Musik]
hier kommt es gerade der halter des
produkts will uns sagen warum sein
produkt so tolles heißt sie alle
herzlich willkommen natürlich
insbesondere auch die höheren aber nur
ganz kurz
da gibt es ja viele die sagen demokratie
das soll mitmachen bedeuten also ich hab
keinen bock drauf ich will lieber offen
vorm fernseher sitzen ich muss meinem
wagen waschen so und jetzt soll ich auch
noch alle vier jahre wählen gehen ich
bin auch keine maschine schafft das
nicht einfach weil das mitleid das große
stichwort demokratie ist in gefahr weil
40 prozent der leute sagen mittlerweile
sie können sie in deutschland auch was
anderes vorstellen ich mir nicht also
ich bin eine demokratie ist absolut
notwendig muss rein
es muss so eine meinungsvielfalt
herrschen aber das was im moment hier
abgeht das also hier sage ich mal 450
jahre degenerierte adel mit
populistischen meinungen um sich
schmeißt und das diesen mist leute
glauben dass caniza dies ist okay im
prinzip das ist schon in ordnung aber
das problem dass sich prinz
grundsätzliche fahre ist dass man in
deutschland alte nicht mehr alle sagen
darf das ist das darf man in deutschland
nicht mehr sagt zigeunerschnitzel
[Musik]
die kölner schlüssel ist ein begriff wo
ich nicht den [ __ ] eigentlich mit
einer sonder der spitze zueinander
stütze ja und das ist das problem was
ich grundsätzlich jahre und beim
negerkuss man sie eigentlich auch eher
den kunsten jagen
wir haben und kosten und nicht weniger
ja genau diese grenzenlose egoismus ist
unerträglich und dagegen kämpfe ich an
diese rasende egoistischen migranten die
reinkommen und immer nur sagen ich ich
ich ich das kann ich schon mal fertig
machen ich sage es gibt auch in der
politik solche leute und es gibt auch im
wirbelt um solchen leute und das lehne
ich ab
sie sagen zb deutschland den deutschen
nur für unten sich vor
ja das sich rasend egoistisch und dann
kommt so ein bisschen jetzt ist ja so
dass wir alle miteinander das gefühl
haben demokratie fällt uns immerzu sie
funktioniert so funktioniert und jetzt
ist die debatte auch mal eine andere
nämlich wie kompliziert ist dass wer hat
die fragen für mich formuliert so ist
weiß ich nicht was das bundeskanzleramt
nein glaube ich dazu sind sind
vielleicht nicht so bedeutend zdf wird
es der intendant gewesen sein der auf
geheiß der bundeskanzlerin mir die
fragen diktiert hat davon bin ich nicht
informiert kann ich mich nicht darüber
äußern
aber sie haben einen leichten verdacht
eine ahnung vielleicht sie haben es
gleich geschafft was bitte schön ist und
das für eine fdp die vor den medien
wegrennt ist etwas ganz neues er hat
keine zeit ja jetzt haben sie natürlich
so gesehen die arschkarte weil sich
jetzt mit mir reden müssen
man muss sich ja oder beziehungsweise
wird sie gerne an einen abgeordneten
weiterleiten
da hab ich aber jetzt gar keine lust
mehr darauf zu warten deswegen nicht
nach hause
das ist die demokratie
sie macht uns allen spaß
doch manchmal ist sie auch ganz schön
scheiße doch meistens sie für uns alle
gut die demokratie
die demokratie
[Musik]
es gibt keine bessere staatsform